GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON JOBS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND THE
ECONOMY I'M ASSEMBLYMAN JORDAN
CUNNINGHAM TODAY I'LL BE
SERVING AS THE COMMITTEE CHAIR.
JOINING ME ARE SIMPLY MEMBERS
CHAO CHAN RAMOS RIVAS QUIRK
SILVA WELCOME AND- TASHA
BOERNER HORVATH TO BE SITTING
IN FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
CHAIR CERVANTES WHO I
UNDERSTAND IS AT HOME TAKING
CARE OF HER TRIPLETS SO WE WISH
HER WELL. I WERE ALSO JOINED BY
BY TONY SIMON'S THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT OF THE COMMITTEE
CHANCHAL LARD TO CONSULT WITH
THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS POLICY
UNIT. AND JOINING US FROM THE
COMMITTEE OFFICES BENJAMIN WAR
HEIGHT THE COMMITTEE SECRETARY.
IF THERE ARE ANY TECHNICAL
ISSUES WITH THE CONFERENCE
LINE- MR WAR HEIGHT IS
AVAILABLE TO ASSIST YOU AND
PLEASE. CALL HIM AT NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO
NINE ZERO. BEFORE WE BEGAN BILL
PRESENTATIONS I NEED TO PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF HOW THE PUBLIC
WILL BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS HEARING. DUE TO THE STAY
HOME ORDER WE'RE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THRUGHOUT THE
CAPITAL. SO WERE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON- BUT WE DO
HAVE A FEW OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM- WE ARE HAVING A
PHYSICALLY JUST AN IN PERSON
HEARING AS MENTIONED IN THIS
SPACE WE CAN ACCOMMODATE SEVEN
MEMBERS- THE STAFF I MENTIONED
AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA. SO LONG AS
YOU MAINTAIN SIX FEET SPACING.
IF ANY THE MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM HERE WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND A LAST YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. RIGHT
THERE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
I'D ASK THAT THE PUBLIC NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. AND YOU
CAN SEE THEY ARE COVERED. YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING. OR
RETURN YOUR SEATS AND PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL INCLUDING IN THE
ELEVATOR. IN ADDITION TO BEING
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF ONE OF
OUR WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE IN
THE CAPITAL. THOSE WITNESSES
WILL APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO
MEMBERS CAN WATCH THEIR
TESTIMONY LIFE. DELIVER FROM
OUTSIDE THE HEARING ROOM YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO ASK QUESTIONS
OF THESE WITNESSES. THERE MAY
BE A SLIGHT DELAY FOR THE
STREAM FROM THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM SO PLEASE BE
PATIENT. WE ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. LET ME
REPEAT THAT EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE YOU
WILL NEED IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. AGAIN
THAT'S. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY JOBS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS WELL AS
ON YOUR TV SCREEN IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING. ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR ON
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVE STREAM LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
AGAINST THE BILL. YOU WILL
REMAIN ON THE LIVE LINE IT WILL
NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATE PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE LINE. AND
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO NINE ZERO. AND THEN WILL
BE THERE TO HELP. I ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
pWEBSITE IS H. T. T. P. S. COLON
FORWARD SLASH FORWARD SLASH. A.
J. E. D. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA
DOT GOV. I WANT TO THANK YOU IN
ADVANCE FOR BEARING WITH US AS
WE IMPLEMENT NEW METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE BEING MINDFUL
RESPECTFUL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK
ALL THE LEADERSHIP AND RULES
COMMITTEE STAFF OF WORKED
DILIGENTLY TO ALL OF US TO HAVE
A SAFE RETURN TO THE CAPITAL. I
WANT TO GIVE A BRIEF OVERVIEW
OF TODAY'S HEARING. AT THE JEDI
HEARING WE HAVE FOR BILLS ON
FILE ITEM FOR- BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI. HAS BEEN
WITHDRAWN FROM THE HEARING AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
THERE ARE NO BILLS ON CONSENT.
THE COMMITTEE STAFF OF PERFECT
PREPARE TO SUPPLEMENT A LIST OF
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION AND EACH
MEMBER HAS THAT AT THEIR DESK
THAT LIST IS ALSO AVAILABLE
ONLINE AND THEIR COPIES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. OUR I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A QUORUM AND WITH THE
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SO WE CAN FORMALLY ESTABLISHED
CORE. CHAIR CUNNINGHAM HERE.
BOERNER HORVATH HERE CHECK OUT
YEAH GEN YOUR RAMOS THERE.
THREE OF US QUIRK SILVA YEAH
MISTER CHAIR YOU HAVE A QUORUM
THANK YOU NOW THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED QUORUM WERE READY
TO BEGIN TO HEAR BILLS. I
BELIEVE WE'RE WAITING FOR
MEMBERS TO PRESENT BILLS. IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME I'M HAPPY
TO DO THE COMMITTEE BILL FIRST
THEY WE SWITCH UP THE ORDER.
AND THIS QUIRK SILVA IF YOU
WOULD. KILEY CHAIR THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY I'M
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARON QUIRK
SILVA HAPPY TO- HERE THE
COMMITTEES BILL TODAY. WE HAVE
AB THREE THREE SIX EIGHT- WHICH
IS ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE
BILL- MISTER CUNNINGHAM ARE YOU
READY YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
LIKE TO FIRST ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WAS
SITTING COMMENT FIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS. THANK YOU EXCEPT OF.
AB THREE THREE SIX EIGHT AS A
BIPARTISAN COMMITTEE BILL IT'S
DEVELOPED TO SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT CHOOSE TO USE
THEIR EXISTING OP OPTION TO
PETITION THE STATE AGENCY TO
MODIFY OR REPEAL AN EXISTING
REGULATION. THE BILL
AUTHORIZES- CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE ECHO BIZ AND
THE SMALL BUSINESS LIAISON AT
EACH RELATED AGENCY TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ADVICE TO A SMALL
BUSINESS ON HOW TO FILE A
PETITION AS WELL AS PROVIDE
FEEDBACK. TO THE RULE MAKING
AGENCY AS TO THE VALIDITY OF
THE PETITION. WITHOUT THEIR
PROFESSIONAL AND PUT A STATE
AGENCY MADE A DIET AND PETITION
FOR REGULATORY MODIFICATION
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING THE REAL
WORLD IMPACT PARTICULARLY ON
SMALL BUSINESS. BETTER
INFORMATION. ALWAYS LEADS TO
BETTER POLICY MAKING. WITH 88%
OF BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
HAVING FEWER THAN TWENTY
EMPLOYEES. SMALL BUSINESSES
OFTEN STRUGGLE WITH REGULATIONS
THAT ARE DESIGNED TO ADDRESS
LARGE CORPORATIONS LIKE AMAZON
OR DELL COMPUTERS. ON THE
CONFERENCE AND I BELIEVE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS NICOLE
RICE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. OF WHO WILL BE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT. AND I ALSO
WANTED TO LET THE PUBLIC KNOW
THAT GO WE HAVE A CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IT IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN SO
WE WILL BE TAKING WITNESSES IN
THE KILL AND WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME TO CALL RICE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS. AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WELCOME.
THAT'S RIGHT FOR YOU HERE. IT'S
POSSIBLE SINCE WE SWITCH THE
ORDER UP SHE WAS NOT. AIRED BUT
I THINK SHE'S THEY SUBMITTED A
LETTER IN SUPPORT YES THEY ARE
CORRECT OKAY AND THAT IS A
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. IF SHE
JUMPS BACK ON WILL TRY AND GET
HER IN THERE I DO WE ALSO HAVE
ANYBODY IN THE HEARING ROOM
THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. ALL RIGHT SEEING
NO ONE DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON
THE CONFERENCELINE THAT WANTS
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AND LATER JOHN OCCUR IN SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE LINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT TO HAVE MS
RICE IS JUST GETTING ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE I'VE JUST GOT
THAT NO OKAY SO WE CAN WAIT A
SECOND HERE FOR HER. IF WE HAVE
ANYBODY ELSE WHO WANTS TO. MAKE
A COMMENT IN SUPPORT ANY
COMMENTS FROM OUR MEMBERS WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FROM THIS. FOR AN
MISS NICOLE NICE. BOB LET'S
RIDE AS DURING THE SECOND. THAT
WE GET A MOTION AND A SECOND
AND WE DO HAVE OF FROM THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION OF COAL
RICE WELCOME. A MAN CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- APPRECIATE BEING HERE
TODAY NICOLE RIGHT CALIFORNIA
MANY FACTORS AND TECHNOLOGIES
THAT CREATION AND I HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY THREE
SIXTY EIGHT- AT THE ANALYSIS
APPROPRIATELY POINTED OUT A
SMALL BUSINESSES. WILL NEED ALL
THE HELP FRANKLY THAT THEY CAN
GET THROUGH NAVIGATING THE HOPE
IT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND MANY
TIMES THESE SMALL COMPANIES DO
NOT HAVE THE MANPOWER OR THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO EXERCISE
THE RIGHT OFFENSIVELY. FRANKLY
BENEFIT FROM THE BEST STATIC
THAT FOR THEM. AB THIRTY THREE
THREE EIGHT WALKER A CREW THAT
OF NECESSARY CáC IT'S SENATE
BY. TO HELP SMALL BUSINESSES
IMPRINT SMALL YOU. NAVIGATE BUT-
AND CPAS THE I AGREE. SHE AND
THE REGULAR WILL. IN ORDER TO
BE THAT COMPLIANCE DRIVING JOB
<c.green>REATORS THAT THAT THE DESIRE</c>
TO BE SO WITH THAT FOR THESE.
WE ARE SUPPORTED THAT THE BILL
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
WHEN THE BILL COMES UP FOR.
ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE ANY ELSE ON THE LINE OR
IN OUR CHAMBERS HERE THAT ONE
TO SPEAK IN THE- ALL RIGHT SEE
NINE REMOVAL TO. IF SOMEBODY
COME ON NOW OKAY DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. IN THE CHAMBERS. ON THE
LINE. TELEPHONE NINE DIFFERENT
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. HEARING NO OPPOSITION- WE
WILL OPEN IT UP TO THE MEMBERS
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEE NO QUESTIONS WE
WILL TAKE IT BACK TO MISTER
CUNNINGHAM WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SURE I'LL BE BRIEF- PROUD
TO BE HERE TO PRESENT THIS BILL
I THINK IT'S A MODEST STEP
FORWARD AND WILL SISTER SMALL
BUSINESSES IT'S A PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS- IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AUTHORED AB SIX FIVE SEVEN
WHICH WAS SIGNED BY GOVERNOR
BROWN THE PUT. THE SMALL
BUSINESS LIAISONS IN EVERY
STATE AGENCY AND I THINK THIS
JUST EXPANDS SMALL BUSINESSES
ABILITY TO SPEAK TO THEIR
GOVERNMENT I THINK IT'S A GOOD
STEP BUT I WOULDN'T
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT. AND
AGAIN I SHOULD HAVE MADE MY
COMMENTS WEALTH I ASKED FOR
COMMENTS BUT I WILL ALSO JOIN
IN I HAVE. AND THIS THIS
COMMITTEE AS I HAVEN'T BEEN ON
I BELIEVE FOR A YEAR NOW. AND
THIS IS WHAT WE NEED TO BE
TALKING ABOUT AT THIS TIME. WE
KNOW THAT- THERE'S BEEN SOME
SUPPORT- THROUGH THE KERRS ARE
ACT BUT SOMETIMES THAT DOES
SUPPORT DIDN'T GET TO OUR
SMALLEST BUSINESSES SO
EVERYTHING WE CAN DO AT THE
STATE I THINK. IS GOING TO BE
EAST CENTRAL TO KEEP NOT ONLY
OUR BUSINESSES OPEN. BUT TO
KNOW THAT WE SUPPORT THEM. SO
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND DO A ROLL
CALL VOTE. FOR AB THREE SIX SIX
WHICH WILL BE. A DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MISTER SECRETARY DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CUNNINGHAM HI CUNNINGHAM HI A
BURNER BAR OR VIA FIVE BURNER
HI SHALL SHIAU HI SHE CHEN I
WORKS. I QUIRK SILVA I RAMOS
ROM HI LOU. WE HI. THE IS A
SEVEN ZERO THE VOTE IS SET ZERO
AND THAT IS THE TO WE WILL
BRING MEETING BACK TO CHAIR
MISTER CUTTING IS MEMBER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF. FIRST UP IN
FILE ORDER IS AB THREE ONE ZERO
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA
RUBIO. IN BEFORE YOU BEGIN YOUR
PRESENTATION- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO I NEED TO GIVE EVERYONE
NOTICE AGAIN THAT THE PHONE
LINES ARE OPEN FOR WITNESSES TO
GET IN THE QUEUE. THE CALL IN
NUMBERS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN
PLEASE BEGAN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER TURN
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY I'M PRESENTING
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE ONE ZERO
ONE WHICH WILL INFUSE CAPITAL
INTO LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
THROUGH PRIVATE INVESTMENTS. IN
FACT INCENTIVIZE BY A
CALIFORNIA AT NEW MARKETS TAX
CREDIT OR SEE AN- EMPTY SEAT.
I'M PROUD TO JOIN ASSEMBLY
WOMAN CERVANTES IN INTRODUCING
THIS LEGISLATION AND I THANK
HER FOR HER LEADERSHIP AS CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE SHE HAS
ADVANCE MANY BILLS THAT BENEFIT
CALIFORNIA'S OUT CALIFORNIANS
STATE RIGHT. AB THREE ONE ZERO
ONE IS THE NINTH OF VERSION OF
A BILL ATTEMPTING TO ESTABLISH
A STATE N. M. T. C. IN THE PAST
THE BILL HAS STALLED DUE TO THE
COST ASSOCIATED. WITH PROVIDING
THIS EIGHT TO SMALL BUSINESSES
AND UNDERSERVED COMMUNICATION
AT COMMUNITIES. HOWEVER OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE ADOPTED THE
PROGRAM REPORTED RETURN ON
INVESTMENTS OF UP TO THIRTEEN
TO ONE WITH THE N. M. T. C.
PAYING FOR ITSELF WITHIN TWO
YEARS OF IMPLEMENTATION. AS.
REFLECTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. THIS IS PROVEN DATE
OF A SHOWS THAT E. AND SEE F.
HIGHS ARE ABLE TO DRAW IN.
EIGHT DOLLARS IN PRIVATE
CAPITAL FOR EVERY STATE DOLLAR
IN CREDITS. ECONOMIC
DISPARITIES AMONG DIFFERENT
REGIONS OF THE STATE AND
BETWEEN NEIGHBORHOODS WITHIN.
OTHERWISE ECONOMICALLY STABLE
CITIES WERE ALREADY AFFECTED. I
AFFECTING CALIFORNIANS AS WE
BEGAN TO ADDRESS THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT MANY
COMMUNITIES WITH THE
ECONOMICALLY DISTRESSED
DESIGNATION STILL HAVE NOT
FULLY RECOVERED FROM THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT GREAT RECESSION.
THESE REGIONS NOW HAVE COVERT
NINETEEN CRISIS PUTTING
ECONOMIC RECOVERY EVEN FURTHER
INTO THE FUTURE. GIVEN THIS LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES ARE
INEVITABLY LOOKING AT THE
LONGER LONGEST RECOVERY TIME
FRAME. IN ADDITION COVERED
NINETEEN DEATHS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTING
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR OR A LACK
OF ACCESS TO QUALITY HEALTHCARE
AND STABLE HOUSING MAKES
RESIDENTS EVEN MORE VULNERABLE
TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. AT
THE STATE AN MTC CAN PROVIDE
LONG LASTING RECOVERY BENEFITS
TO LEVELING INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS BY INCENTIVIZING
INVESTMENTS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THE COMMUNITY
PROJECTS. AS THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY WORKS THROUGH ITS COVERED
NINETEEN ECONOMIC RECOVERY
STRATEGY AB THIRTY ONE ZERO ONE
IS A USEFUL TOOL AND ENSURING
ECONOMIC SECURITY DURING THE
CRISIS WHILE CREATING A MORE
EQUITABLE FUTURE. THE N. M. T.
C. MODEL IS BASED ON EXISTING
FEDERAL PROGRAMS AND HAVE
ALREADY BEEN USED IN ELEVEN
STATES. OVER HALF OF THE
INVESTMENTS ALREADY DEPLOYED
UNDER THE FEDERAL NMTC WERE IN
AREAS WHERE THE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATES ARE A HUNDRED AND 50%
ABOVE THE STATE AVERAGE. THE
MODEL WORKS THROUGH EQUITY
INVESTMENTS AND QUALIFY
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS OR SEE DFI AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
DEVELOPMENT ENTITIES CD. THE
PROGRAM WORKS BY INCENTIVIZING
PRIVATE INVESTORS WITH A TAX
CREDIT GIVEN IN EXCHANGE FOR AN
EQUITY INVESTMENT IN THE CD OR
SEE DFI OF THEIR CHOICE. THE
CDF I OR C. D. E. MUST USE THIS
EQUITY TO MAKE INVESTMENTS
WHICH WILL RESULT IN ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA. THE
FUNDS ALLOCATED PURSUANT TO
THIS BILL WILL BE DISTRIBUTED
AND ADMINISTERED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND CURRENT BILL LANGUAGE WILL
PROVIDE FOR FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN TAX CREDITS ANNUALLY.
BASED OFF OF YEARS OF DATA OF
IDENTICAL PROGRAMS FUNDS IN
THIS BILL COULD NOT BE USED FOR
REAL ESTATE BUSINESSES CHARTER
SCHOOLS GOLF RELATED TO STOP IT
IT IS DEVILISH MEANT OR BARS
AND CARD ROOMS. NATIONWIDE CD
EASE AND CDF EYES CAN APPLY BUT
ONLY THOSE ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE
AN ABILITY TO OPERATE IN LOW
INCOME REGIONS IN CALIFORNIA
WILL BE APPROVED. FOR
TRANSPARENCY PURPOSES
INSTITUTIONS APPROVED FOR THESE
TAX CREDITS MUST PROVIDE ANNUAL
REPORTS TO THE GOAL BIDS. ON
THEIR USE AN IMPACT. AFTER TWO
HUNDRED DAYS ANY UNUSED CREDITS
ALLOCATED SHALL REVERT BACK TO
GO BIDS FOR REDISTRIBUTION. AB
THIRTY ONE ZERO ONE IS BASED ON
THE ECONOMIC PRINCIPLE THAT
TARGETING SIGNIFICANT
INCENTIVES TO LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES ALLOW THESE
COMMUNITIES TO MORE EFFECTIVELY
COMPETE FOR NEW BUSINESSES. AND
RETAIN EXISTING BUSINESSES
WHICH RESULT IN INCREASED TAX
REVENUES LESS RELIANCE ON
SOCIAL SERVICES AND LOWER
PUBLIC SAFETY COSTS. ARE
CONSTITUENTS AND BUSINESS
OWNERS WILL ALSO DIRECT BENEFIT
DIRECTLY BENEFIT FROM THE
RESULTING SUSTAINABLE ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS THROUGH IMPROVED AND
NEIGHBORHOODS BUSINESS
EXPANSION AND JOB CREATION.
WITHOUT PROGRAMS LIKE THIS THE
ECONOMY CANNOT SUSTAIN THE
CURRENT LEVEL OF UNEMPLOYMENT
AND WE BUILD. AS I STATED. THIS
BILL IS A JOINT EFFORT WITH
ASSEMBLY WOMAN CERVANTES THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE. AND IS
A NEWER VERSION OF- THIS RIVAS
IS A BILL LAST YEAR I AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIGHT FOOT. THE BILL.
THANK WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND- BEFORE WE GET TO THE
VOTE I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE
JULIAN CAN YET TODAY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ON THE CONFERENCE LINE
MISTER CAN YET IF YOU'RE ON THE
LINE YOU CAN BEGIN. YEAH THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BUDGET
COMMITTEE PRESIDENT CEO TO
CALIFORNIA'S BACK CHAMBERS- WE
REPRESENT. OUR MEMBERSHIP IS
COMPRISED OF OVER EIGHTY FIVE
HISPANIC AND PICK CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE BUSINESS LOCATION.
THAT THE STATE. REPUBLICAN I
DON'T THE INJURED OF. OUR
OVERHEAD HURT BY IS BACK GOING
TO BUT BOTH THE- OF THE DIVERSE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY AS WELL. I
DO BELIEVE THAT. THE COMMITTEE.
AND ESPECIALLY TONY STARK AND
YOU COULD. ALL HARD WORK. SHE
HAVE DOING IT COORDINATING THE
AND WE SORT TO CHANGE AND OTHER
BUSINESS SO SHE- TO HER THEY
WERE FONG CALLS OR COPPER CALLS
AGAIN I DID WANT MAKE SURE. I
TONY THAT BUT IF YOU CARE TO
AND CHAIRED OF OCT. I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY- THIS LISTENING
AND THAT OTHER THIS MORNING
OVER 75% OF THE POSITIVE CASES
OF KOBE IN NINETEEN FARMING
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THE FIVE
POINT 4% OF DEATH- ABOUT BLACK
PEOPLE COUNT FOR THE HIGHEST
NUMBERS AT FIFTY POINT 9% AND
THIRTY FIVE POINT 7%
RESPECTIVELY. AND BEYOND THOSE
NUMBERS BUT WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND EVERY EVERYONE- THAT
THERE ARE MILLIONS OF LIKE TO
KNOW THAT ARE SUFFERING THE
IMPACT OF THIS PANDEMIC. AND AS
NEW REGULATION DEMANDED TO BE
PUT IN PLACE WHAT DO YOU KNOW.
AND MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
ARE STRUGGLING TO KEEP THEIR
DOORS OPEN. I KNOW REALITY
SOMETHING WE EVEN STOPPED
COMING BEFORE CORPORATE
NINETEEN. AND IF NOT SHOT WHERE
SHOCKWAVE IN A MATTER OF WEEKS.
THIS IS THE TIME I LIKE TO KNOW
THE OTHER DIVERSE COMMUNITY. I
NEED AT THE MAKE THEIR LIFE THE
TOP PRIORITY. A CALIFORNIA
TAKES STEPS TO BE COVERED. UP
WE WILL NEED PROGRAMS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA NEW MARKETS TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM THE FOCUS.
EXPENDABLE INVESTMENT INTO
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
HELP YOU'VE NEVER HEARD MORE
EFFECTIVELY COMPETE FOR NEW
BUSINESSES AND RETAIN EXISTING
BUSINESSES- BUT NINETEEN
ATTEMPTING NOT ONLY THE
RESILIENCE. BUT ALSO THE
ABILITY OF BUSINESSES
INSTITUTIONS AND GOVERNMENT.
NATIONAL A NEW MARKET TALKED
QUITE CAN PLAY SIGNIFICANT ROLE
IN HELP DEVELOP COMMITTEE
RECOVER FROM ECONOMIC FALLOUT
BUT CALL AT NIGHT. BY
COMMITTING TO DRESS BUT- TO
SERVE IT UNDER. LOWER IN POPPED.
AND BY SUPPORT NEIGHBOR WE BY
THE- STRATEGY GIVEN BY LOCAL
GRASSROOTS STAKEHOLDERS.
CALIFORNIA MUCH INSURE THAT
RESOURCES AND MEASURES IN
PLACE. TECH SUPPORT THEY CRIED
ECONOMY. AB THIRTY ONE OH ONE
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF NEW
CAPITAL RESOURCES FOR
DEVELOPMENT IN LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS. NEIGHBORHOODS
AND COMMUNITIES THAT NEED YOU
TO MAKE A BOLD STRUCTURAL
CHANGES. COULD NOT LOSE THEIR
OPPORTUNITY OF REACHING THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM. AFTER THE
CAPITAL. I GIVE IT BUT TOP. I
THOUGHT OF MY WORK WHICH IS TO
CALM MORE THAN FIFTEEN YEARS
AGO TIME AND TIME AGAIN SMALL
BUSINESS DEPRIVE OF GOING THEIR
OPERATION HIRING NEW EMPLOYEES
AND MAKING SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL CONTRIBUTION IN THE
COMMUNITY. NINE DIFFERENT
VERSIONS OF THIS BILL AT LEAST
HAVE BEEN BE PRESENTED BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE SIX TWENTY TECH
ARE SMALL USINESSES CANNOT
AFFORD ATTEMPT FAILED ATTEMPT
TO MAKE THINGS RIGHT AND I DO
WANT TO THANK GOD ASSEMBLY
WOMAN ALONE. RUBIO FOR CARRYING
THIS BILL AND HER SUPPORT OF
THE NEW MARKETS TAX BUT THANK
YOU THAT YOU CAN. THANK YOU SIR
AND WE ALSO HAVE NICOLE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ON
THE LINE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
MS RICE PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ONCE
AGAIN- NICOLE RICE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGIES
THAT. AND I JUST WANTED TO BE
ABLE TO SIGN- I'LL COME BACK
EVERYONE WE APPRECIATE YOU ALL
COMING BACK TO SACRAMENTO TO DO
THE IMPORTANT BUSINESS AND
RELATED TO OUR RECOVERY- WE'RE
HERE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY ONE A ONE AND I WANT TO
THANK- ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO AS
WELL AS- THE CHAIR IN HER
ABSENCE OF FOR THE SPELL. I
MEAN LIKE BEAST TYPE-
INVESTMENT PROGRAM BETTER
SPECULAR AND HAVE THIS CYCLE IN
NATURE BECAUSE AS LOOK BAD BY
THE PREVIOUS CALLER IT NOT ONLY
BENEFITS. THOSE WHO ARE MAKING
THAT FINANCIAL INVESTMENT BUT
IT ALSO INVEST IT IT BENEFITS
THE COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL BE MAY AND THE
BUSINESSES WILL STAR. AND WE
HAVE SEEN AS THE MANUFACTURING
INDUSTRY GREAT SUCCESS TO THE
FEDERAL MODEL AND PROGRAM IN
MANY STATES AND COMMUNITY. AND
WE DEFINE EVEN THE SMALLEST
LEVEL HECTIC FAST AB ONE
COMMUNITY THAT IT HOLDS OUT OF
THE SPIRAL OF POVERTY INTO
PROSPERITY AND A. B. THIRTY ONE
OH ONE CAN HELP INCENTIVIZE
CONTINUE TO GROW. AT A TIME
WHEN WE NEED IT FOR SMALL AND
MEDIUM SIZED MANUFACTURERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THIS OPPORTUNITY
IT CREATES A GREAT BENEFIT FOR
MANY COMPANIES NOW FOR LOOKING
TOWARDS RECOVERY AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW THEY ARE WE TO
DO THAT PROCESS. ADDITIONALLY
AS WE KNOW AND IT WAS POINTED
OUT IN ONE OF THE COMMITTEE
PREVIOUS ANALYSIS. THAT THE
BAND. INDUSTRY HAS A TWO POINT
FIVE THAT MULTIPLIER SO ANY
MANUFACTURING INVESTMENT THAT
IS MADE. AND ONE OF THESE. IN
IF AT THE MORE BOB AS A BY YES
NO I IT JUST AND REVENUE INTO
THE- OPEN FOR THE THREE I J. AS
HAPPY SUPPORT. AB THIRD ONE
ALLOW AND A WE ASK YOUR EYE BUT
WHEN THE BILL COME UP FOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MS RICE MISTER
MODERATE IS A ELSE ON THE COP
LINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. LANE
JOHN OCCUR IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT
THE TIME WE HAVE NOBODY IN THE
QUEUE THANK YOU SIR NOW LET ME
ASK IF ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. SEEING NO
ONE MISTER MODERATOR IS ANYONE
ON THE CONFERENCE LINE THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
NOW KERN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THE TIME WE
HAVE ONE IN Q. IT JUST BE A
MOMENT. ENTER THE FIRST PERSON
WE GO TO OF IT'LL BE TWO LINES
SIXTEEN LINE SIXTEEN YOU ARE
OPEN. PLEASE GO EIGHTY
HARDENING OF HI KATIE HARDENING
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION- ETA
OPPOSES EXPANDING OUR CREATED
NEW TAX CREDITS AT THE TIME AND
WILL NOT EXISTING TAX CREDITS
ARE- REVIEW- QUITE THEIR
EFFICIENCY. AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM MISTER
MODERATORS ANYONE ELSE ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE THAT WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN THE
QUEUE. NOW LET ME ASK IF ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. HOUSING NO
ONE I'LL TURN IT BACK TO.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS. I WE HAVE A SINGLE
QUESTIONS WE HAVE PREVIOUSLY
EMOTION I THINK BY MID UPPER
ARE BROUGHT SECONDED BY MS
QUIRK SILVA. OR MAYBE THE OTHER
WAY AROUND. SO HI MS RUBIO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROVIDE A
CLOSING STATEMENT I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AT THIS POINT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR A
CONSIDERING THE BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. UP I GUESS I SHOULD HAVE
DONE MY CHAIR COMMENTS. THAT
WOULD BE VERY BRIEF- STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL FOR ALL THE
REASONS MENTIONED IN YOUR
PRESENTATION. AND BY THE
SUPPORTERS. AND I THINK IT'S
VERY TIMELY GIVEN THE SITUATION
WE FACE ECONOMICALLY IN OUR
STATE. THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THANK YOU MAYBE THIS TIME WE
CAN. GET IT. TEN STRIDES A
CHARM YES VERY WELL THAT. THANK
YOU FROM THE NUMBER. THAT WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS- DO PASSED TO
ASSEMBLY AT COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR CUNNINGHAM
HI CUNNINGHAM I-
BOERNER HORVATH HI.
BOERNER HORVATH HI CHAO SHALL I
CHEN GEN I QUIRK SILVA QUIRK
SILVA HI RAMOS RAMOS HI
THREE OF US THREE OF US BY A
VOTE OF SEVEN ZERO MEMBERS THAT
VOTED SEVEN TO ZERO IN FAVOR AB
THIRTY ONE NO ONE IS OUT. THANK
YOU MS REVIEW NOW MOVE TO THE
SECOND ITEM ON FILE WHICH IS AB
THIRTY TWO OH FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS BEFORE HE BEGINS
HIS PRESENTATION AS HE
APPROACHES THE- CHAIR THERE LET
ME GIVE EVERYBODY NOTICE AGAIN
THAT THE PHONE LINES ARE OPEN
FOR WITNESSES TO GET IN THE
QUEUE. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THE HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. HI MR SALAS
UNDERSTAND YOU BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS IDENTIFIED
IN THE ANALYSIS UNDER COMMENT
FIVE. CORRECT THANK YOU.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL DROP
THOSE AMENDMENTS AND MR SAUCE
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TWO OH
FIVE- JUST TO RESTATE I DO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
WORK. OF AB THIRTY TWO OH FIVE
ESTABLISHES THE REGION'S RISE
GRANT PROGRAM WITHIN GOBIZ THAT
WILL ENABLE REGION'S TO
COLLABORATE AND CREATE
INCLUSIVE REGIONAL STRATEGIES
FOR ECONOMIC PROSPERITY.
CALIFORNIA STRUGGLES WITH
INCOME EQUALITY ACROSS THE
STATE SPECIALLY AT PLACES LIKE
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE NOT AMONG OTHERS
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE TOP 5%
OF CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS FATHER
AVERAGE INCOME GROW. BY MORE
THAN 15% WHILE THE BOTTOM FIFTH
SOUTHERN AND CONTRACT BY MORE
THAN 5% IN THIS THE FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE SEVEN POINT ONE
MILLION CANNOT. BASIC WHAT.
WORKS LEYVA DE. AT THE SORT OF
THIS YEAR WILL CALIFORNIA SO.
ON AVERAGE OF AROUND 4% WE KNOW
MANY PLACES IN THE ENTIRE STATE
ACTUALLY HAD DOUBLE
UNEMPLOYMENT AND NOW WITH. A
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH CODE WE
CAN ONLY IMAGINE THAT THOSE
NUMBERS WILL ONLY INCREASE
DRASTICALLY. AB THIRTY TWO OH
FIVE DRIVER COMMUNITIES
TOGETHER TO CREATE INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO TACKLE THE
BARRIERS THAT PREVENT- INLAND
CALIFORNIA FROM EXPERIENCING
THE HEALTH AND PROSPERITY OF
OUR GOLDEN STATE EXPERIENCES
ANOTHER REGIONS. OF THIS BILL
WILL GIVE THOSE GROUPS. WHICH
NO THE REGION'S THE BEST THE
RESOURCES AND TOOLS THEY NEED
TO HELP MAKE THE REGION AS
PROSPEROUS. AS OTHER AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA. WHAT THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE
AND YOU KNOW I HAVE THAT.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
ON THE LINE THANK YOU MISTER
CELIS I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE
MICHAEL WEINBERG WITH
CALIFORNIA FORWARD ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE. MISTER
WEINBERG PLEASE BEGIN. HERE ARE
THANK YOU CARE CUNNINGHAM AND
MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY AND TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS BIRTH LEADERSHIP
ON THE- WE OFFER REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE STAFF
WHAT WITH LITERALLY THE BACK
AND BOTH COPPER HAD THE BILL
ABOUT THAT. BUT I'VE EVER READ.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL WHY BURKE.
IT WAS REALLY GOTTEN MY NAME IS
MICHAEL WHY BURKE AND ON THAT
THE OF CALIFORNIA FORWARD AND
MORE THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF THE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION FOUNDED
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE FOCUS
ON MAKING CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
AND GOVERNMENT WORK FOR
EVERYONE AND ALL THE STATE'S
REGION. ALONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TO WORSHIP AT WORK
OUR ALLIANCE OF REGIONAL TRIPLE
BOTTOM LINE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT LEADERS BECAUSE THE
ANNUAL CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC
SUMMIT. FIFTY FIVE PART OF THE-
RIVER BY BIT THE THOUGHT PROFIT
EQUITY ENVIRONMENTAL AND
TYPICALLY OCCURS FROM
ORGANIZATIONS FROM THE REDWOOD
COAST TO THE IMPERIAL VALLEY.
AND YOU'LL BE MANY OF THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS BUT THAT
SUPPORTERS AND THE BILL
ANALYSIS. ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS
MENTIONED AB THIRTY TWO A FIVE
CREATE THE REGION'S RISE GRANT
PROGRAM. THE HELP THAT DIVIDE
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
REGIONALLY BASED INCLUDE AFFECT
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
STRATEGIES. THE PARTICULAR
IMPORTANCE TO THE STATE
GRAPPLED WITH HOW BACK TO
CONFRONT THE IMPACT OF
CORPORATE NINETEEN INTO
PRODUCTION. AND HOW TO LEVERAGE
THE UNIQUE OUT THAT A COMMUNITY
THE BILL STRONGER MORE
EQUITABLE AND RESILIENT
REGIONAL ECONOMIES. WE FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT THE STATE THE
THINK REGION HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE STRATEGIES
THAT BEST FIT THEIR LOCAL
NEEDS. OUT THAT AND
OPPORTUNITIES. IT MIGHT SEEM
LIKE A NICE TO DO THAN A YOU IN
THAT YOU'RE A USED BY THAT. BUT
IF WE DON'T APPROACH ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN A FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT AND MORE INCLUSIVE
WAY WE WILL SIMPLY RECREATE THE
ECONOMY THAT WE HAD. WHICH
WOULD DEEPLY ADEQUATE BALL
ALONG RACIAL AND GEOGRAPHIC
FINE. I COULD MATTHEW THAT WE
DO NOT WANT AND ECONOMIC
RECOVERY WE NEED AN ECONOMIC
WOULD DO ALL. AND BUILT INTO
THE FEDERAL COURT FOR BACK
AFTER. IN ADDITION TO THE WORK
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE YOU'LL
HEAR ABOUT BACK. WE LEARNED A
LOT FROM THE PRESS NO DRIVING
ISSUE THAT THAT TOOK PLACE OVER
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF. PETER
APPERT. DEMONSTRATED THAT
BUSINESS. LOCAL GOVERNMENT
EDUCATION EQUITY GROUP THAN
OTHERS. AND WORK TOGETHER TO
CREATE. INCLUDED AN INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES. STRAIGHTENED AND
GROW. THEIR REGIONAL ECONOMY.
SIMILAR PROPERTIES ARE UNDERWAY
IN PLACES LIKE KERN COUNTY IN.
BUT WITHOUT CONSISTENT SUPPORT
AND CLEAR CONNECTIVITY TO LOCAL
REGIONAL AND STATE POLICY THEIR
IMPACT WOULD BE PERMITTED. AB
THIRTY TWO OH FIVE ADDRESSES
BOTH ISSUES AND MOVED UP TO
WORK CREATING MORE INCLUSIVE
GROWTH IT WILL ALLOW ALL
CALIFORNIANS THE PROPER. IN
CONCLUSION WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE STATE TO HELP
BUILD PAINFUL COMMUNITY
RESILIENT BUT THE STORK OF
EXTRAORDINARY HARDSHIPS WE ARE
SEEING RIGHT NOW WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO OH
FIVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. MY GOOD
FRIEND PROPERTY UP. THANK YOU
MISTER WEINBERG WE ALSO HAVE
PARKER NEO WITH THE INLAND
EMPIRE ECONOMIC PARTNERSHIP ON
THE LINE MR NEO PLEASE BEGIN.
FUTURE CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. HI MY NAME IS PAUL
GRIOT FROM THE PRESIDENCY OF
THE INLAND EMPIRE ECONOMIC.
SPEAKING STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY TILL FIVE. THE PARKING
ON THE PARTNERSHIP IS OUR
REGIONAL LEADERSHIP ACROSS
SECTORS- OTHER WORKS CLOSELY
WITH THE BUSINESS GOVERNMENT
EDUCATION LEADERS TO IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR THE
PEOPLE OF THE INLAND EMPIRE.
FOUR POINT SIX MILLION THE
APPROXIMATE APPROXIMATELY 11%
OF CALIFORNIANS. YOUR FOCUSED
ON HELPING TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
THEM TO BUYING TRIPLE BOTTOM
LINE SOLUTIONS TO OUR ECONOMIC
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIAL
CHALLENGES. AB THIRTY TWO OH
FIVE EIGHT THE STATE PROGRAM
THAT WILL HELP DRIVE IN SUPPORT
PROSPECTOR AND CROSS
JURISDICTIONAL COLLABORATION
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
INCLUSIVE REGIONAL ECONOMIC
GROWTH STRATEGIES THAT CAN HELP
THE STATE RECOVER IN A MORE
STRATEGIC WAY. WE AREPART OF A
BROAD COALITION OF LOCAL
REGIONAL STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT IS
SUPPORTING AB THIRTY TWO OH
FIVE. BECAUSE WE KNOW FIRST
HAND THE VALUE OF AN ALL HANDS
ON APPROACH TO REGIONAL
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES IN THE NEED
FOR THE SUPPORT OF SUCH EFFORTS.
EMPIRE I HAVE BEEN ACTIVE IN
THE INLAND ECONOMIC GROWTH AND
OPPORTUNITY INITIATIVE. WHICH
OPERATES IN COORDINATION WITH
THE BROOKINGS INSTITUTE AND
AIMS TO BRING TOGETHER CROSS
COUNTY LEADERSHIP. TO INCREASE
LOCAL ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY BY
INVESTING IN BETTER PATHWAYS TO
GET JOBS IN APPROVING
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES. ARE YOU
P. WAS ALSO INVOLVED IN THE
CREATION OF THE GROWING INLAND
ACHIEVEMENT INITIATIVE. WHICH
IS WORKING TO INCREASE POST
SECONDARY DEGREE ATTAINMENT IN
DECEMBER DINO AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. LET'S SEPARATE WAS BORN
OUT OF A GRANT FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S INNOVATION AND
HIGHER IT. APPROACH TIGHTENING
IN RESOLVING THE CHALLENGES
THAT PERSISTED IN COMMUNITIES
FOR MANY DECADES HAS BECOME
EVEN MORE IMPERATIVE BUT THE
COLBERT NINETEEN CRISIS. AS YOU
KNOW THE CRISIS HAS CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATED. AGGRAVATED BUT
WIDESPREAD ETHNIC INCOME IN
GEOGRAPHIC INEQUITIES THAT
EXIST WITHIN OUR STATE.
REGIONAL OF THE THIS MODEL
WORKS THERE'S WORK TO BE AN
EMPIRE WE BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO GIVE ALL REGIONS
OF THE STATE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PLAN FOR INCLUSIVE AND
SUSTAINABLE GROWTH THE TRULY
MEETS THE NEEDS OF OUR REGIONAL
COMMUNITY. I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME TODAY. I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT AB THIRTY
TILL FIVE. AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GRUNOW MISTER
MODERATOR IS OR ANYONE ELSE ON
THE CONFERENCE LINE THAT WISHES
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
PLEASE JUMP YOUR IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. LOOKS LIKE- WE DO HAVE
THREE THAT ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE JUST BE A MOMENT TO GET TO
THEM. RESEARCHER LIKE TO.
QUESTION YEAH HOWEVER MOTION BY
MISTER ROBERTS SECONDED BY
MISTER CHAN. HAND ON THE PHONE
LINE SO WE CAN FIRST GO TO LINE
TWENTY EIGHT ONE TWENTY EIGHT
YOU ARE OPEN. HI THIS IS JULIE
A JOURNALIST LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
ARE WE SUBMITTED AT THE CORE OF
THE MEN LETTER PRIOR TO
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH AUTHORED SPONSOR ON
THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT ON THE PHONE NINE WE GO TO
LINE TWENTY NINE ONE TWENTY
NINE YOUR OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- MY
NAME THE ENGINE MEDI HERE IN
SUPPORT FOR THE FEEDBACK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND LASTLY- WE
GO TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN LINE
TWENTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
HELLO GIVE ME FICTION AND ENTER
THE COMMITTEE- RAINY THIRSTY ON
BEHALF OF VALLEY BE THERE NOW.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU IS ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. SEEING
NO ONE NOT TURN BACK TO MISTER
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE COP AND SIGNED THAT WISHES
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. NOW IF YOUR OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. THE TIME THERE ARE NONE
IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NO ONE ALTERNATE BACK TO
THE MEMBERS FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE- I
BELIEVE WE HAD A MOTION AND A
SECOND ALREADY- MISTER CELIS-
IF YOU'D LIKE TO PROVIDE A
CLOSING STATEMENT THAT'S
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU FOR BRING
THIS BILL FORWARD I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT I THINK REGIONALISM
AS- THE WAY TO GO AND WE'VE
SEEN WORKING PARTNERSHIPS ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE
WORKED I THINK- I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE INSULT AGAIN FOR.
WHAT HEARINGS THE BEST A NOT
THIS EVER DONE. I PRAISE-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR CUNNINGHAM
HI. YOUR CUNNINGHAM HI ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH HI.
BOERNER HORVATH I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAO. CHECK OUT I
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAN CHAN I
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF. RAMOS
I ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US.
THREE OF US HI THE VOTERS SEVEN
ZERO THANK YOU OF MEMBERS ON A
SEVEN ZERO VOTE AT THIRTY TWO
OH FIVE IS OUT THANK YOU MISTE
CELIS AGAIN- NEXT WE MOVE TO
THE THIRD ITEM- IN FILE ORDER
THAT IS AB THIRTY THREE OH
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA- BEFORE HE BEGINS
PRESENTATION THANK YOU SIR-
AGAIN I'D LIKE TO GIVE NOTICE
THAT THE PHONE LINES ARE OPEN
FOR WITNESSES TO GET IN THE
QUEUE. BECAUSE FOR THE HERE.
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO NINE FIVE
SEVEN IN THE ACCESS CODE YOU
WILL NEED IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. A MISTER
GARCIA I BELIEVE YOU'LL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
BILL ANALYSIS HUNDRED COMMENT
FIVE THAT THAT'S CORRECT WHICH
CHAIRED BY TWO WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR HER
WORK. ON THIS ANALYSIS IN THE
WORK OF COURSE ARE BILLS THAT
ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
LEAVING CALIFORNIA ON THE
PATHWAY OF REAL ECONOMIC
RECOVERY- THIS BILL AB THREE
THREE ZERO SEVEN ONE ESTABLISH
TO CALIFORNIA IN A FACTORY
DISASTER KNOWN. HE PROGRAM.
THAT WOULD SUPPORT STATES
EFFORTS IN THE STATE EMERGENCY
RESPONSES AND RECOVERY EFFORTS.
TO MEANT TO PRO PROMOTE QUALITY
MANUFACTURING JOBS AND SUPPORT
MANUFACTURERS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES WHILE FOR MEETING
OUR STATE UNIQUE PRODUCTION
NEED. BERNIE PANDEMIC OR STATE
MARKET. IT ALLOWS AN AVENUE FOR
BUSINESSES TO RETOOL REPURPOSE
AND EXPAND PRODUCTION AND
DISTRIBUTION PRODUCTS NEEDED TO
PREVENT THEM FROM ACCUMULATING
DEBT LOSS. LOSS OF EMPLOYMENT
AND A SHORTAGE OF ESSENTIA
GOODS. THE BILL WOULD ALLOW FOR
NEXT AFFECTED AN AREA AFFECTED
BY STATE OF EMERGENCY IN
DECLARED A DISASTER BY THE
PRESIDENT ADMINISTRATOR OF THE
US SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION. OR THE US
SECRETARY OF AGRICULTURE OR
DECLARED TO BE IN A STATE OF
EMERGENCY BY THE GOVERNOR TO
ALLOW THE BACK. AND MAY. HELLO
THE BANK TO PROVIDE LOANS AND
LOAN GUARANTEES TO BUSINESSES
AND MANUFACTURING SECTOR
SUPPORT STATE EMERGENCY
RESPONSES AND RECOVERY EFFORTS
THERE'S A- LONG LIST OF. ITEMS
THAT ARE INCLUDED THE BILL TO
BRING FORWARD SOME TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. THE PROGRAM
WOULD BE ADMINISTERED BY THE-
AYE BANK OF THAT IS ALSO
AFFILIATED WITH GOLD IS THE
STATE'S ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
ARM AS AS I WOULD TO REFER TO
IT AS- A WITH THAT THAT
RESPECTFULLY WOULD ASK
AFFORDABLE. THANK YOU MR
GARCIA- MOTION BY MISTER- IS
BOERNER HORVATH SECOND BY MS
RIVAS- AT THIS TIME MISTER
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
IN GERMAN ON THE PHONE LINES
PRIEST PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE ONE IN
THE QUEUE IT'LL JUST TAKE A
MOMENT TO GET TO THEIR LINE.
AND SO WE GO TO LINE THIRTEEN
LINE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DAVID COMES ALL THE
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCE ASSOCIATION HAPPY TO BE
HERE IN SUPPORT I THANK THE OFF
THE BRIDGE TEACHING SUPPORT
MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER GONZALEZ- MISTER
MODERATOR IS ANYONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. AT THE TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE. IS THERE
ANYONE THE HEARING ROOM THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. AS SAYING NO ONE
MISTER MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE CONFERENCE LINE
THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THE GERMAN ON THE
PHONE LINES THIS IS ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE NOT POSITION. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NOBODY IN THE
QUEUE. THEN I'LL TURN TO THE
HEARING ROOM IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. SEEING NO ONE I WILL
TURN IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR DISCUSSION.
PLEASE I WANT TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I THINK
ONE OF THE LESSONS WE'RE
LARNING FROM COVE IN NINETEEN
IS THAT THE LONG SUPPLIES
CHAINS FOR MANUFACTURING ARE
ACTUALLY REALLY DETRIMENTAL FOR
US TO BE AGILE AND TO HAVE IT
OUR MANUFACTURING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO MEET THE MOMENT
OF THIS CRISIS SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRING FOR THAT
THIS FOR AND IT'S VERY GOOD DEL
SAUDIS. BRING TODAY THANK YOU.
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO ECHO
THOSE COMMENTS AND ALSO ADD.
YES PERSONALIZED MANUFACTURING
IS THE SECOND BIGGEST
EMPLOYMENT SECTOR MY DISTRICT-
IT'S OFTEN- THAT'S NOT WELL
KNOWN ACTUALLY AS EVERYBODY
THINKS OF US ISNOT TOURISM AND
WINE AND SO FORTH AND SURFING
BEACHES AND TOURISM AND ALL
THAT. BUT THAT'S VERY CRITICAL
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR STATE
ECONOMY AND- YOU KNOW THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE GOOD JOBS THOSE ARE
HIGH PAYING JOBS- SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRING THE BILL
FORWARD ON HAPPY TO SUPPORT
TODAY. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. DO YOU
WISH TO PROVIDE A CLOSING
STATEMENT WELCOME MY ANY OF YOU
WHO WISH TO ADD ON AS CO
AUTHORS YOU'RE PLEASED TO DO SO
AND- RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
YEAH YEAH I WOULD LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR I THINK I
AM I'D LIKE TO BE ON AS A CO.
AS AS AS WHAT I SO THAT JUST
LEAVES MISTER CHAN WHAT'S
WHAT'S GONNA. THERE THERE WE GO.
WELL I THINK I KNOW HOW THIS
BILL IT'S GOING DOWN. MA'AM
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB THREE
THREE OH SEVEN THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
HI BOERNER HORVATH I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAO. CHECK OUT I
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHANCE. CHEN I
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS. RAMOS HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US. THREE OF US HI THE
VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO THE VOTE IS
SEVEN ZERO A. B. THIRTY THREE
OH SEVEN IS OUT THANK YOU AGAIN
MR GARCIA. ARE WE AS PREVIOUSLY
NOTED ITEM FOR- AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE BY MISTER
MURATSUCHI HAS BEEN WITHDRAWN
AT THE AUTHOR'S REQUEST- WE
PRESENTED IT- THE COMMITTEE
BILL HE BE THIRTY THREE SIXTY
EIGHT DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS
THE NEED TO ADD ON TO THAT BOAT.
WE DO NOT THEN. I BELIEVE
UNLESS THERE'S SOMETHING I'M
MISSING THAT THAT CONCLUDES
THIS HEARING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.